of peace to everybody how are you you
come
to get some food for the soul you've
been replete with everything else
but it's not satisfying the soul money
can't buy that happiness
it won't bring you peace not even a
six-pack a piece you can't buy it
greetings of peace to all those that are
tuning in from all over the globe
in our live audience here in dallas
texas
alhamdulillah praises to the creator of
the heavens and earth who has given us
this platform that we can share the
purpose of life with the world and today
special topic with special guest sunnah
that way
that way that's pleasing to god jesus
was on the sunnah moses was on the
sunnah
prophet muhammad peace be upon him he
taught us the sunnah do we know the
sunnah the way
and we're here with our guest who's one
of the original guests here on the
dean show sheikh yasser brijas
be right back with his important topic
the way the sunnah
here on the deen show
this is the theme
this is the the
graduate from medina university
alhamdulillah instructor with el magdev
institute yes
so people can go to the deanshow.com you
have your special section there i
mentioned
one of the original guests back in like
2007
2008 we started 2006 a little bit after
that you were on the show
i remember those days masha'allah you're
back with us again we mentioned the
sunnah
that's the way jesus he talked away to
the people the way to worship god the
way to be in a way that's pleasing to
the creator moses is it safe to say they
were on the sunnah is this correct
this is correct absolutely and the last
and final messenger sent the mankind to
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
he taught us the sunnah tell us what
does this word mean when we say sunnah
talk to us
in terms of sunnah the word the meaning
of the word sunnah and
i would say the lamest terminology it
just means the lifestyle of the prophet
muhammad
in the linguistic meaning of the word
sunnah itself it means the way
just like you mentioned a few times but
when it comes to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
when all the prophets before him it
means their lifestyle
and we believe that the lifestyle of
these prophets was
divine in terms of that allah made them
role models for us and everything that
they've done
in their capacities as messengers of
allah they need to be followed that way
that lifestyle
it's considered basically the way that
allah wants the followers of those
prophets
to find this way for them and that's why
we see that the prophet salallahu
every time whenever he delivers he would
say
muhammad in sallallahu alaihi wasallam
it means the best guidance is the
goddess of the prophet salallahu that
means that's his way
is the best way to and of course when we
talk about the way of the prophet
um here we're talking about his way in
in more business sophisticated
terminologies the orthodoxy of the
practice of islam
in theology and also in practice as well
as in management
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi in this
program
specifically we want to revive that way
the way of
all the messengers of god we know that
we have the verbatim word of god the
quran
uh-huh it's tamper-free taber proof and
it's original and we have
the sunnah the way of the prophet can
you separate these two
well if we're going to talk it in that
broad meaning of sunnah that means we
have to speak about the sunnah of the
anbiya the prophets all together in
terms of akhida
that means their faith their their their
belief
in allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala was all one
in terms of their practices
meaning the actual lifestyle they led
their people
it was accommodating to their own times
so we see that at the time of musa
there was a specific meaning legislation
that they need to follow
as part of the way of musa that he gave
to beni israel that came from allah
when it comes to to uh isa it is also
the way of islam in terms of now
you have the same sunnah the same path
the same lifestyle of believing in allah
but in terms of now the practices
depending on their time
he he brought them a specific way but
when come to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
in terms of theology as well the
definitely the same path is the same
sunnah
but when it comes to the practices it
was a little bit different
now that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he was sent as the final
messenger of allah azzawajal
his way of life his lifestyle it is
supposed to be the way for all people to
look up to and find examples and find
guidance through that's what the prophet
saw allah said in himself he said
muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam the
best guidance is the guidance of the
prophet muhammad
some people have this misnotion that
when you say sunnah they attribute to
something voluntary something you can do
you can't do is this correct
are there things in the sunnah that are
obligatory upon muslims
these are technical definitions of the
term sunnah itself when it comes to the
term sunnah
uh an academic basic division of sunnat
comes into four categories or five
categories
there's the linguistic category of
sunnah that means way it's basically the
way of life in general
and now when it comes to what we call
and that is the
the actual uh uh practice of ibadat our
devotional act
sunna is equivalent to the me to the
term
must have recommended that and perhaps
this is what we're referring to over
here
if you want to do the sunnah did you
pray the sunnah that means that you pray
the voluntary act that is not
obligatory upon you did you fast mondays
and thursday which is a voluntary act in
this case it's considered muslim
recommended act
that's how they define sunnah in that
sense then there is also the
the theoretical definition of sunnah and
that is uh the way of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in his in his
speech in his actions and his silent
approvals
this is now technical definition that is
for what we call
then you have the definition of usual as
well
which is that the equivalent or the when
you say sunnah in
theology eventually it is uh the
opposite to
what we call vida means innovations in
practice
or even in theology so with the term
surname that we're referring to in this
conversation perhaps right now
is the musta have definition meaningful
so when you go to an imam and you ask
them
do i have to pray that two or four raqqa
after salat
they will tell you it's sunnah which
means they mean it's recommended
it's muslim it's not obligatory but it's
definition it's actually recommended
however one thing that many people
unfortunately they kind of yeah
they undervalue the sun so when you tell
them
this is sunnah they say oh hamda so it's
not
yes yes which means it's not obligatory
the meaning of that statement it's
basically that means i don't have to do
it
well yeah you don't have to do the
sunnah but if you want to
truly to be a true follower of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
you need to realize that this is the way
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
and if he did that salawat allah if he
practiced
we should follow his example because
that's what he said he said
al hadi muhammad in sallallahu so i
really it hurts me when some people they
come and ask
and they want to know if if they have to
fast mondays and thursdays
do i have to pray do i have let's say to
pray
mullein do i have to fast three days
every single month and so on and when
you tell them well you don't have to
but this is considered sunnah let me say
it's a recommended act of the prophet
salallahu
and for them it's just like okay thank
you that mean i don't have to do that
now that definitely it's it's
undermining the authority of the
of the lifestyle of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and they just
undervalue the meaning of following his
example
now in the spirit of this show is called
reviving that way the sunnah
so we're going to throw some things out
in the course of the show
and try to revive it many don't know
about it some you know
forgot about it so before we go to break
sajdah
the prostration of thankfulness is this
something that the prophet peace be upon
him did
how do we do it how do we implement it
talk to us about this
well to make a sujood or prostration
you know to show your gratitude and
thankfulness allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
it is one of the practices of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
it is one of these sunnahs that he
practiced
so when he received good news when he
receives victory from allah
he goes down into prostration position
to show his gratitude
and his and his uh thankfulness to allah
so something like this perhaps it's
completely forgotten
in in so many in the life of so many
muslims meaning when they have good news
what do they do
they go and they post that on facebook
they tweet that unfortunately
instead the first thing they should do
is they say alhamdulillah
and they go drop down drop down in
prostration
frustration the creator of the heavens
this this is that
frustration of thankfulness you don't
have to have wudu for that no we do
and you don't even have to that the most
authentic place or correct opinion on
this issue you don't have to have
for that you don't even have to face the
qibla for this because this is basically
a spontaneous now act of of gratitude
you just drop down and you just be
thankful to allah of course if you have
the wudu
and you have also the full covering for
it and so on that's definitely his best
position
however if it just happened that you
have then then you heard the news
when you didn't have wudu and you want
to show your gratitude to allah azza
there is nothing wrong
dropping down into judah and thank allah
subhanahu wa so the brother who's been
looking
not for a girlfriend but a wife and he
finally finds it or the woman that's
looking for
a husband and she finally finds that man
in her life
she drops down says alhamdulillah drops
down and thanks allah actually
that's a practical example they need to
do this yeah
but so do this is a good start
we're going to be right back with more
here on the dean show
you say that you do not believe in jesus
you have stepped outside of islam you
cannot be a muslim it attended our faith
to believe in and love jesus christ
why is it then when it comes to one of
the most important decisions in life
we literally abuse ourselves it's not
that the main thing we're looking for is
to see what type of money he has so that
he can treat my daughter like a princess
it's not about that he is
back here on the dean show and
we're talking about the sunnah the way
and
we talked about that all the prophets of
the creator of the heavens and earth
they were on that way of submitting to
the creator calling the people to submit
to god that pure monotheism
and we're continuing that tradition and
giving some examples
now how can people now you got this term
right you have this term that people
inventing things and they're confusing
how could we differentiate what sunnah
and what's something that's been
concocted by a human being
isn't that is that necessarily a bad
thing now that you bring something into
the religion that the prophet didn't
teach how could we differentiate
the term buddha itself in terms of
linguistic definition it means something
invented out of uh basically no example
no previous example for
something unique that being made up now
in terms of religion it's the same thing
but now it's exclusively in the acts of
worship
so for example inventions such as cars
uh
watches uh microphones cameras all these
things and so on this considered bidder
in a linguistic definition which is
considered okay
i mean there is nothing wrong with that
and this had to practice these things
that
use them in a halal way of course but if
something is now becomes
an invention in in faith and religion
and practice of the deen
and that is the thing that is considered
dangerous because our deen when allah
gave muhammad the final almost the last
few
revelations of the quran giving him now
the near end
like when the victory of allah comes to
you
and you see people coming in waves to
islam
because you need now to start preparing
yourself through tasbih uh
and seeking forgiveness forgiven when
the prophets are receiving those
statements
he was getting ready now to the end and
one of the final revelations was on a
very special occasion
which is an arafah during the hajj
season so
the prophet saw allah says
today i have completed your religion for
you so and i have
perfected my my blessings that bounty
allah bless us
and satisfied with islam as your
religion that means allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
was pleased with the prophet salallahu
and his delivery of this faith
so it was perfect and complete that's
why
it's a very short highlight in terms of
the number of words on there
and it's considered one of the most
valuable hadith that even imam in
november
chose to include that in this collection
before hadith many people perhaps they
know this hadith but prophet sallallahu
alaihi
says
whoever invents anything in this
religion that which was not
basically originally in it it's rejected
we should be rejected and we should not
uh change the way the prophet sallam
did things in terms of in terms of deen
now there's a confusion over here people
they sometimes
they confuse the buddha in in in in the
non-devotional acts of the prophet
salallahu so they come to you with an
argument they say
well the prophet he never uh drove cars
he always
went on camels of allah that you ride on
a camel
i said no that's not the sunnah the
sunnah is to have a ride
that's what the sun is the ride of the
time back then was a camel was a horse
was or something else
today the ride of our time cars bikes
and so on so whatever that is available
in our time
that's the sun of the prophet saw allah
but was not the son of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that we start inventing things in our
worship
the things we call inaudib innovations
that we should stay away from
and just remain on that very pure and
clear message and way of rasulullah
before his death he says
the night and the day are distinct which
means it's very clear you could you
could
see through easily
no one goes no one stays away from that
path of rasulullah
but will go astray and he will be doomed
so it's a responsibility of the muslims
men and women
to make sure that whatever they do they
do this according to the example
tell us going into again sunnah say a
person is praying
you know they're fasting they're doing
many of the rituals of islam
but they have bad character bad
etiquettes bad manners
gossiping backbiting i mean is the
sunnah also synonymous with having good
character development absolutely this is
one of the biggest misconception about
sunnah you will find some people masha
allah
they're very passionate about following
the example of rasulullah
in devotional acts like the way they
pray the way they fast and even
sometimes they go
the way they look and the way they dress
up and so forth may allah reward them
for that passion
some other people they associate with
that unfortunately
bad behavior and they think that being
stern and being you know rude and so on
as
something that it required to force
people to follow the path of rasulullah
and that is wrong on the other hand some
other people they think that
following the example of rasulullah is
considered absolute not for our time the
21st century
now it depends on how we define the
sunnah as we said if you go literalist
on that example to say you have to write
camels i agree
that's wrong but if you're not gonna
abandon everything the prophet salallahu
as a way of worshiping the way of
understanding things is definitely
something we need to take in
consideration that reminds me actually
what true story one of the
scholars once mentioned and it's it's
it's funny and sad at the same time
when the hajjaj in mecca they come from
all over the globe so they come
sometimes carrying their cultures their
way that they're taught to follow the
sunnah
maybe it's not the most accurate thing
so this individual he was
during the had season and he was praying
in one of the local masjid in mecca in
aziz
so as he was praying there he prayed
next to one of the locals
so one of the ways people they do after
salah they shake hands
you say shaykh hand in the same allah
except from you they shaykh with the
people next to them right and left and
so on
which is not common in in in the culture
over there perhaps
so this this [ __ ] he turns to the
person who is local
next to him and he says or something
like that
so that local unfortunately he pushed
him with his hand he pushed his hands
you know and roughly and he told him
this is innovation that had he answered
spontaneously with a
very any natural in it he told him and
uh being rude is sunnah
me i understand this might be wrong but
is being rude that's the sin that's the
example you want to give me
so eventually what we know from this is
that the rasulullah
were indeed the interpretation of the
quran and the exact meaning of the son
of the prophet salallahu
ayasha when she was asked about the
example of rasulullah which she was
asked
how was the manner of rasulullah
don't waste your time investigating if
he was different at home from his
outside
because whatever he go wherever he goes
he's always the same
it's the quran itself now okay
you know when you invite someone to
righteousness say people benefit right
now
from some of the things that we're going
to revive and they do are we going to
get the reward for it inshallah
absolutely one of the sons of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
that you go and deliver the message
deliver the message as a matter of fact
one of his last advices and his last
instructions
when he was given his fight is farewell
he said salawat allah
that you deliver even if it was one
single ayah just deliver my message
even if it was one single ayah no one as
far as i know in this crowd or anyone
who's perhaps listening to us from the
muslims
no one can claim that they don't know at
least
one single surah not even i so if you
know that surah
deliver that message even if you deliver
that to another muslim who doesn't know
that surah
so when you do that you're delivering
now the sunnah of the prophet salallahu
and you are following the son of the
prophet salallahu
the good news about this is that for
every person
who is guided because of you being now
that the mean of delivering that part of
the message to them
you'll get your reward they'll get their
reward and on top of that
you get the reward their reward for for
doing
what you have instructed them to do as
the son of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
subhanallah this continues as a running
charity for you
generations after you die for everyone
who benefits
you're getting the reward for that
inshallah that's right that's right do
the sunnah do the sunnah of all the
messengers of god including the last and
final messenger and share
if you care share this message of peace
peace acquire by submission to the will
of god
islam share with the world be right back
with more here
on the deen show it comes to you the
truth
and the attribute of the one who created
you that he's won and alone
running this universe that he doesn't
become
born he doesn't die he doesn't eat and
go to the bathroom
this is not god they've got problems
here yeah it's this
doesn't make sense who was jesus
worshiping because this is recorded in
the gospel
despite all of the other issues about
the gospels we put those aside we just
said it's mentioned there that jesus
worship god who protects
us from hunger welcome back to the dean
show and we're here with sheikh yasir
brijas
now i'm sorry i didn't inform you this
but i'm up on you one already allah
tells us to race
toward jenna by doing good so i i hope i
was able to revive the one about sugar
uh such
the prostration that even the non-muslim
right now if he's inspired he's watched
some of the previous shows
and he's i'm going to thank god i want
to ask god for god they can
prostrate right now and say god guide me
uh guide me to if these people
are on the truth i want to be on the
truth they can make that prostration
right now can they
absolutely this is even the sunnah of
their prophets
uh the prophet isaiah the prophet musa
jesus moses
they all they all did that in their
lifetime it's even mentioned in their
book as a matter of fact
absolutely yeah it's also part of our
sunnah as muslims that every time you
receive good news it's good
that you go you drop down and prostrate
to allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
being thankful and grateful to him okay
so i mentioned one i want you to come
catch up to me i got two more i'm gonna
throw two two more let's see who wins at
the end
one is smiling at your
brother is that not a charity you know
someone we frown
you know and you see your brother let go
you don't look at him or the sister
saying smiling to her sister another one
is you're at the target
or you're at the jewel and you see your
your brother
you've identified he's a muslim saying
salams to him you know you see your
family tell your you know wife said
salaam said a sister some don't give it
back but if we give the salons back we
give that greeting with this smile
is that a sunnah absolutely this is even
one of the most important basic sunnah
of the for the muslims to practice
you know it seems that many people they
think that being too serious
means so it's better for you to be
around the people so serious
so that they don't run over you
eventually if you smile they might think
you're easy
and as a matter of fact that's the whole
purpose that's the point of smiling
the point of smiling is that people they
realize that you're easy
and they can be easy with you and that's
why the prophet salallahu
he was serious he was the most dedicated
the most devoted at the same time
the most smiling person of the um
even he said i've never met the prophet
salallahu in my life
i never met him but he smiled in my face
now if you look at the life of allah
he lived with the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam since he was 10 years
old
when the prophet arrived into medina and
then he stayed serving him for about 10
11 years
so from he was 10 years old until 21
years old
can you imagine the lifespan of anas
he's seeing the prophet salallahu
smiling in his face
when he was a young boy a teenager and
even who was a young adult
that mean rasulullah was smiling in the
face of everybody and he was just making
his life
easy other sahaba they said i've never
seen the pro
the prophet he was the most smiling
person ever
salawatu i actually studied that
i read some papers on the on the meaning
of smiling and how effective that is
of course it takes a lot easier uh
uh muscles you know for you to relax
when you smile that when you frown and
then you get upset and angry
but what is most important is that
smiling in the face of others
it's an indication it's a sign that you
can associate with me
and that is why the prophet salallahu
says
should i guide you for something that if
you do you're going to love one another
you spread peace among yourselves saying
salaam to each other and when you say
salam
you smile in the face of other people
and when you do that with
every person that you see around you you
create that culture of peace
we live in a culture that's saying hi
and good morning and so seems to be kind
of weird so therefore
there's always tension in the community
but imagine everybody says salaam and
good morning and salaam alaikum and
smiling in the face of one another
it makes it look much easier actually
for us to interact that is
one beautiful sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
i know a brother who will see people at
a home depot
he'll identify that's the muslim he sees
you know the beer the kufi or something
he'll go up to him and say assalamu
alaikum he never met the brother but
it's salaam because he knows that
he heard the sunnah the hadith with the
you can go ahead and expound on this the
sins fall off when two brothers
come with intention you know and they
greet each other is this true that is
true i mean
one of the statements mentioned one of
his books about
the meaning of follow why do we need to
practice the same
kind of student of the prophet salallahu
let's say when you go to the bathroom
why do you need to follow particular
procedure for example when you eat why
do you have to follow particular let's
say soon of the prophet salallahu
when you pray when you walk when you
talk when you go to hajj and son
one of his observation at least from
when he was basically looking into islam
from outside
one of his observations is that when you
have everybody
following the exact same model the exact
same role
imagine what that creates in the
community creates harmony
it creates it drops all these
differences unfortunately in a very
diverse community is there a lot of
tensions because of what
because of love of differences now if
you can bridge these differences to
become
as part of that all over all sunnah of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
that brings peace so that's that's very
important and that's why when people
they they they live the life of the
prophet salallahu and they follow the
example of the prophet salallahu
it becomes easier for them to relate to
another let's say sisters for example
when they walk anywhere in this
community anywhere they go they can
easily identify one another through the
hijab for example
that's easy for the brothers they can
identify themselves sometimes with a
beard
and sometimes not actually which is one
of the stories i had in one of these
airports
uh i was traveling actually and then
subhana i came
face to face with someone else with that
with a beard also a beautiful person
almost we dressed alike almost so he
told me salam alaikum
in the actual pure arabic pronunciation
of assalamu alaikum
i looked at him because of his bill and
i smell his mouse mind and my face
i recognize he was actually a rabbi so i
said
this i said to him in his in his hebrew
basically
which is the simple the same word salaam
alaikum
it was kind of an awkward moment but at
the same time we felt at ease
that we looked in terms of you know
wearing the beard which is the son of
the anbiya
even ibrahim al-islam had a beard even
isa uh jesus he had a beard even moses
musa made a beard so it's the sun of the
ambian when we look at each other
we just smile and he said assalamu
alaikum in the arabic pronunciation so
imagine if you can relate to one another
even though you're a different faith
imagine if you're actually muslims
how much you connected to another if you
follow the sunnah of the prophet
salallahu
we only have a couple more minutes so
real quick so if a sister
she can obviously identify another
sister in the modest hijab she should go
out of her way to
say salaam's tour give her the greetings
of peace why not there's
an opportunity we all want those moments
sometimes you feel alone
you could change you could make the the
life of someone
and i do that when i travel a lot in the
airports and i see a lot of sisters work
working in the airport with hijabs and
you can see on their own and so on
the moment you pass by and just say
salaam alaikum respectfully you just
feel at ease
that someone recognized and said i'm in
a place like the airport when you have
to be careful you know sometimes yeah
but just say salaam alaikum what's wrong
with saying the airport
and when you do that you just feel easy
imagine a sister she's another sister
and she goes to her says salaam alaikum
how are you doing and so on it just
spreads again peace tranquility in the
community you got to give us one now
i mentioned a few go ahead give us
something that comes to the top of your
head
that muslims that we can revive that you
see that's been forgotten from the
sunnah
well one of the things that people they
really forgot about the sun of the
prophet sallallahu assalam really it's
the matter of
the manners of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam we have so much devotion
to his salah we have seen so much
dedication
from the muslim ummah regardless of
their backgrounds regardless of that
particular school of thought that they
follow
it's a beautiful thing that we're
dedicating ourselves to the sunnah and
the example of the prophet salallahu
but one of the things that we're still
behind is actually following his
heart and his manners the lack of
forgiveness
of tolerance of of being you know
accepting the others and eventually
being you know
willing to talk and listen and deal with
one another and so on even if sometimes
it's tough still we need to open our
hearts for another
that is one of the beautiful sunnah of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi i would
love to see the muslim um the community
insha allah with allah
walk on very well may the creator of the
heavens and earth help
us to accomplish that to live on the
sunnah
to die on the sunnah the way that's
pleasing to the creator before we meet
the creator
may allah grants you the best in this
life and hereafter thank you for being
with us
thank you very much and there you have
it reviving the sunnah the way of jesus
moses abraham the last and final
messenger sent to mankind and prophet
muhammad peace be upon him they had the
best of character
they were on the best of ways and that
way was to call people to establish a
relationship
with the creator the one who created
creation to worship him alone
and not his creation to prepare for the
day of judgment by doing good
living good living by the sunnah get to
know the sunnah
and live it and visit us here every week
on the deen show
you can call us at 1-800-662-islam to
learn more
and we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you
you